hi my name is buzz Hays I'm the global
lead of meeting entertainment solutions
for Google cloud and then we have a very
special guest here today Dan Linn who is
the vice president of infrastructure
services at Viacom CBS we're here today
to talk about content migration
strategies to cloud now as you all can
imagine we're experiencing some fairly
challenging market conditions at the
moment so a lot of media companies are
starting to look into their archives as
a way of finding material to monetize
while we're on a hold pattern for other
productions to be launched so we have a
number of companies that are looking
into their archives to find content to
license to other people to stream on
their OTT platforms and because of these
delayed content pipelines for new
productions there's a lot of interest in
finding gold in these archives so people
are looking back into media archives of
all kinds and that extends back beyond
digital media it actually extends back
into analog media which is something
that we'll talk a little bit about today
- our definition of media entertainment
is everything whether it's film video
audio tape photographs documents they
all qualify and they're all finding new
relevance in this this day and age so we
find that with a number of sports
leagues there's a lot of interest in
trying to leverage older content people
love to watch highlights of older games
so we're finding that across all sports
which is fantastic we're also seeing
that there are a number of new streaming
entities that need more content to put
onto their channels and legacy content
is one of the backbones of some of the
bigger studios like Disney Plus for
example they have a very extensive
archive and they've just started to
scratch the surface actually so digging
into their archives and finding ways to
monetize these older titles is it
couldn't be better timing same with
Apple and other folks like Netflix
they're really looking for ways to
leverage older content as we wait for
newer things to be produced now the
traditional methods of digitization and
storage are fairly laborious and
somewhat costly the very labor-intensive
so what we've
mind is in cloud there are a number of
ways that we can help people migrate
their collections to cloud and that
includes media in any form as I
mentioned there's a lot of analog media
out there which is difficult to monetize
obviously until it's in digital form
until it's cleaned up until it's made
pristine and made available to the
public so we want to make sure that we
have enough tools available for the
folks in cloud to be able to ingest this
material to convert it to the proper
digital formats and then they can start
to bring this this content to market as
you can see here 42% of media CIOs are
struggling with managing their content
in general and this is pre the current
conditions of kovat and the environment
within which we're not producing new
content there's a lot of archived
content out there that hasn't been
monetized it's the analogy is like an
art museum where over 80% of the
collection is typically in storage and
the public never sees it some of these
media archives are quite substantial and
a lot of their material sits behind
firewalls where people can't see it so
now as an opportunity to start bringing
some of that forward now there are some
legacy digitization capabilities out
there in the world and we need those in
order to get material off these analog
forms like videotape and film and audio
for example especially with film film is
a difficult process because it can be
done in slightly less than real time and
video tape is limited by the fact that
we can only digitize in real time so for
the hundred million hours of videotape
that might be out there for any given
entity that wants to digitize things
it's going to take a hundred million
hours to digitize that so we have some
significant challenges ahead but the
idea is to bring all of this material
into cloud so that it can be then
monetized and leveraged to increase the
value of these archives as we go forward
so as an example we did a project
recently with the New York Times where
we help them with their photo archives
they have one of the largest photo
archives in the world and the archive
goes back to the beginning of
photography and so we used a number of
our AI and m/l tools to help the New
York Times to find information about the
photographs not only the visual
information but also by reading the
information that was either hand
written or typed on the back of the
photos about the uses the locations who
might be in the photographs and then
created a database within which they can
search this material at lightning speed
so in the past it might take a few
months for someone to put together a
story for example where they wanted to
do a photo essay or a photo journalistic
exploration of a specific subject they
would have to hire an archivist to go
and through the files manually to find
these photographs to find the
individuals they're talking about which
may not be tagged appropriately and then
send those out so we've gone now from
the manual process to a much more
automated process with a very robust
database which allows people to really
cut the amount of time it takes to get
these stories out to the public so we're
seeing significant increases in the
speed from many many months now to a
matter of days to be able to leverage
the content so this is just one example
now archive migration within Google
Cloud we look at it basically as three
distinct phases the first phase is the
digitization phase we have to get this
material into cloud now some of it may
be digital born already especially
modern motion pictures and television
but they're all shot natively digitally
in fact most all of the workflow itself
is digital there's still a few that
shoot film but primarily it's going to
be a digital workflow those files are
very easy to move to clouds but once you
start talking about other media types
then the idea of ingest into cloud
becomes a bit more labor-intensive there
are more steps involved and we'll
outline some of that that we're helping
with in in this presentation there's
also a quality control aspect to this
there's a lot of media out there and
quality control really requires human
eyes to really make some decisions so
we're helping those human eyes by
leveraging some of the AI tools we have
so that people can have basically a
checklist to go by so when AI find
something that might be suspect or some
quality control software find something
suspect we can put a list together and
put it in front of the people who need
to look at this with their own eyes and
make those decisions for themselves so
it's a much simpler process rather than
having people look at every single frame
of every piece of content on the
generate side once we get this material
into cloud whether it's
born or started as an analog videotape
and then with digitized we create
proxies for that which are very
important for a few reasons
primarily because we need a reference
copy something that we can look at that
we can use to search for material so the
the core of many media asset management
systems is a proxy file and oftentimes
the metadata that goes along with that
is the way people are able to search
these databases so we during this phase
leverage all of the AI and ml tools we
have to be able to provide intelligence
to this data through what's found in the
picture through speech to text we can do
sentiment detection we can do celebrity
recognition we have a number of
different ways where we can build a very
robust database which makes it very easy
to search these mountains of information
and make intelligent decisions on which
content we might want to put out there
on streaming channels for example
indexing the media is extremely
important and we have a tool that we'll
talk a little bit about here it's called
video search which is a new tool that
allows us to apply all of the machine
learning and AI tools that we have as a
single command line it will then build a
database of all of this metadata and
then we can surface that data through a
search API that can be leveraged within
whatever application people want to use
so say for example you're an editor and
your work in Adobe Premiere or an avid
or in Blackmagic resolve you can now
leverage the search capability within
the application itself which means you
no longer have to rely on going to a
media asset management system finding
the clips you're looking for exporting
those clips then re important those
clips into your editing system just to
use them now you can surface those clips
directly within the application that you
want to to process the files with and it
makes it for a much more efficient
process much faster and because we use
natural language processing you'll now
find things that you thought weren't
there or you weren't asking for them
correctly so we're getting incorrect
responses there's no more boolean search
required to find the value in the media
so it's a this idea of indexing media is
extremely important especially when you
have a lot of it and the archive itself
is only as good as this index so there
we have many customers who have many
many petabytes of
eeeh out there and some of it is
multiple versions at the same thing it
could be localized versions of a given
title for example all the different
foreign language versions of something
but it's difficult sometimes when you
have these massive archives to know
where there's duplication so we have a
lot of ways to be able to detect
duplication and help call out some of
this derivative material so that you can
make the footprint of your archives much
more manageable if you will and then we
also talk about preservation storage we
have a number of strategies we talked
about creating preservation masters
especially for videotape where we can
remove all of the compression codecs for
both the audio and the video so we can
have a true archive representation of
that media that could be read in the
future and then finally the third phase
of what we talked about with archive
migration has to do with how we leverage
all of these assets and so I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a second
so as I mentioned we have all these
different types of media whether it's
film or video tape audio tape we have
lots of media on dejah tape right now
both LTO and t10 k and some other older
formats like DLT dap so there's there's
media all over the place and so trying
to get that stuff off of this legacy
media which is non archival to bring it
into cloud which is archival and make
sense of it is one of our key missions
when it comes to this digitization phase
then when it comes to generating the
assets metadata we use the various tools
we have in our AI + ml toolset as you
can see here we generate the proxies as
I mentioned we index that media it's all
fairly automated so when you have a
massive collection you can have a very
substantial database that can be
searched very quickly using natural
language processing to find the material
you're looking for without really any
hiccups
and then finally leveraging the content
especially to get this to the public we
find that the metadata is actually very
useful in direct-to-consumer plays where
people are looking for specific thing
they may not be able to remember the
actor's name but they might remember the
character's name in the show so all of
this metadata can travel along with the
media it would make it easier for the
consumers to find what they're looking
for just like the power of a googol
and then of course our ecosystem
wouldn't be the same if we didn't have
all these great partners to deal with so
we have all of these wonderful content
management and archive migration
partners that we work with regularly to
help leverage the ways we search this
media the way we tag the media the way
we store the media so we we spend a lot
of time with our various customers and
these partners to really integrate and
find the best solutions for folks to be
able to manage their massive media
archives now today we have a very
special guest with Dan Lynn from Viacom
CBS and they are leveraging at Viacom
they're leveraging Google clouds
advanced analytics to enhance their
content discovery and they have lots of
media from lots of different sources and
so Dan is here to talk a little bit
about that but I just wanted to point
out a couple of key things here
certainly with the content
recommendations there are over 4.2
million customers per day looking for
recommendations it's possible now to
provide actionable insights for both
marketing and the ads teams to be able
to analyze in this case 2,500 pieces of
content daily and we deliver in-house
solutions for AI and ml which help
leverage Google Cloud products with just
a few developers in-house so leveraging
the power of auto ml and some of the
other partner tools we have people now
have the power of ML training their own
models without having to be data
scientists so without further ado I'd
like to introduce our very special guest
Dan Lee
Thank You buzz for the introduction so
I'm going to sort of walk through a
little bit about wonder project that we
did with Google it's part of a much
bigger journey that bike MCPS is
undertaking so our journey to the cloud
this project that we did with Google is
specifically around Viacom's content
Viacom CBS has you know a lot of
different contents both on the
television in film in the case of film
of Paramount Pictures so this project
that we're working on a specific be
around the bike on so what we're trying
to do I'm going to walk you through sort
of a little bit of project we'll review
and talk about the business requirement
and sort of the architecture and how we
accomplish this so first a project
overview so we have roughly seventeen
petabytes of content and these content
kind of like what puzzles mentioned
there's a lot of are sort of source
content and where all the derivative
assets are generated - for awfully poor
distribution packaging - multiple
partners and suppliers and then vendors
and so forth so we call these the
content submission master so the idea of
this sort of cloud journey is to move
all the submission master at least make
a copy of it put it in the cloud so that
can be easily consumed so it's sort of
relatively early part of the sort of
content supply chain and once we do are
able to put all these content in the
cloud then it will be readily available
for you know transformation or
distribution and so on and so forth and
and as well as all other for a IML
things that we like to do with these
contents that we weren't able to do
before print so let me kind of talk a
little bit about the business
requirement for the cloud migration so
the total amount
we were talking about for this project
was about 14 petabytes of content and we
need to do this in roughly four month
period
besides moving a copy of the content to
the cloud we need to make sure that the
data integrity is maintained and there's
really two parts to sort of the data
integrity one is making sure that the
content that we while during the
transfer process is not manipulated
identical to the original source so
that's one aspect of the integrity the
second aspect is that you know the
inventory is complete right so we did
not miss anything so every single piece
of content that were substantive to the
cloud copy done made it to Google lastly
if there's any exceptions as a part of a
transfer we all of course need to be
able to easily identify those and then
review them remediate them according so
some of the key questions that we needed
to sort of address is what's the best
way to move those route data in that
short amount of time you know and
there's a couple things that we looked
at one was a tea shop which is basically
the Google transfer tool another method
we looked at was transfer appliance and
then which is where you know they're
shipping essentially you know large hard
drive and then we have to put into the
data center you know move data on to the
on - you know these hard drives and then
ship them back to Google and Google suck
it in into the Google right and then the
last option is the GS detail which is
sort of a command-line other things that
we have to make decision about where do
we store it what year do we store it you
know obviously dependent here and so on
so for and where we store it a different
cost implications lastly is how do we
protect the data this data is sort of
the source assets so you know we need to
make sure in it does not get
unauthorized access or just tampered and
salsify so how do we go about protecting
this data and some different types of so
as
that data protection is you know do we
turn on things like versioning do we end
up using bucket lock or object lock not
choosing to do as well as who has access
and that's basically the I am I am roles
lastly sort of the requirement point of
view we we also want to make sure this
can be done relatively easy easily with
minimum labor just because again we
Viacom CBS is a very large content media
company we have a lot of content and
this is just the first one of many so we
want to make sure that this process and
the tool that we chose are efficient and
another part is that whatever software
we choose to use to do this transfer and
manage or transfer and so on so for you
know ask new requirements come up and
can easily new features can be adding
and we deployed and so on so forth so
that's where the automatic code diploma
deployment comes so conceptually
essentially all these data are on LTO
tapes and it's actually being supported
by diva so we we actually basically need
to pull all these data out of diva from
fortune which was acquired by Oracle and
I think lately also spun out to eco
digital it's a fairly popular man system
that's used across many many medium
payment companies we're gonna load it
onto a local sand storage and we're
gonna use essentially the tea sock
software to eventually move these data
to Google so the primary consideration
on why we chose tea sob was basically
that keysaw handles a lot of the
management for us especially in terms of
validating making sure the data is you
know the integrity is maintained you
know that is relatively easy to operate
there's not a lot of people that needs
to get involved in staging or D staging
equipments and
what have you are loading and unloading
data into physical equipment in the case
of like the transfer client and so T
Saab was sort of the obvious choice it
has a combination of easily use and
least amount of sort of manual
intervention required and so that's kind
of why we take T stop
so y'all use Mickey saw the key stop
just basically handles the data transfer
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
sort of architecture what's important is
that when we're moving all this data out
of diva obviously carry over some of the
proprietary things that's specific to
diba part of what we want to do in the
project is not carry any technical debt
so information that's very specific to
diva for example how objects or
reference and so on support we want to
change the architecture such that we're
using for a more native goods that you
know more conformist for a modern
architecture right so not only do we do
the data transfer we actually did a lot
of manipulations internal file names and
saw software so that by the time it gets
to Google it doesn't have any of the any
of the historical information that's
specific to diva so one of the things
that happened you'll see this workflow I
won't cover all of it but you'll see all
other things that we did by leveraging
things like bigquery and some custom
stuff that's written to basically do all
the manipulation and processing marry
with piece odd was how we were able to
manage the whole data migration to
Google so with that this is sort of the
conclusion of this particular project we
were able to achieve this in four months
one of the key reason that I think is
worth pointing out why we chose Google
out of all our vendors that there are
two key things that we thought was
that's that the Google especially the s3
stores apart one is the fact that
regardless of the sphere of storage the
axis is always been sent aeneas whereas
some of the other
lighters youth wore it on cold earth
here and you need that piece of
information it's not necessarily
instantaneous the second thing that we
thought sort of made Google's stand out
in this use case was the fact that there
is a special sort of continental bucket
that we were able to store to so in a
scenario where we have assets that we
need to protect it and have multiple
copies for example so that's not subject
to sort of localized failures we do not
necessary to make full copies on for
example to availability zones or regions
or what ad there says there's a concept
of a continental region so effectively
that will allow us to achieve that
requirement but without having to pay
double the copy essentially with another
provider so those are actually the key
reasons why we pick Google for this
project so in summary we were able to
achieve this in four month with a lot of
help from Google it was a great
partnership this is the first of many
sort of content library migrations and
as we speak we're now moving on to sort
of the next one which is Paramount
Pictures well thank you Dan that's great
and it's a very nice description of how
you did this as you can see this is this
is representative of how Viacom CBS is
managing their massive archives but Dan
your expanse you pointed out a couple
things here I wanted to ask a little bit
about is the integrity checks the check
sums part of this it's it's an extremely
important part of any of these archives
and if you talk to any archivist whether
they refer to it as a checksum an md5
hash or fixity everyone is concerned
about checking the file integrity of
what those files are as they're stored
in cloud so could you talk a little bit
about that process is that a fully
automated process that's part of your
mam or how does the checksums happen
over times yes it definitely is so the
way we do it today like I said a lot of
stuff is stored on LTO so you know LTO
has a certain life cycle essentially if
you will so we have a business
requirement wherever
year we're actually pulling back every
piece of asset and rehashing basically
read the content into memory and
comparing the md5 against the original
source and that's how we make sure
nothing got changed now obviously
they're saying that there's a match new
copies get you know creative you know
and most most of the time when things
don't match do do sort of you know bit
rot or what added right so it definitely
does occur especially given the amount
of content that we yeah obviously in the
grand scheme of the population of
content we have the amount of bit rot is
actually very very small but we want to
make sure we copy we we're catching
those so that we always have confidence
in our content especially on the film
side which the content sometimes may can
take you know hundreds of millions of
dollars to make we definitely want to
make sure those content are not
contaminated in any fashion
yeah that's a very good point because a
lot of the archive media that's been
used to date is somewhat fragile right
and so I imagine prior to this you had
to have a migration strategy to get from
for example one LTO format to the next
one just to be able to preserve the
archive at some cadence but now once
you've moved things to cloud I think
that you can breathe a sigh of relief
but you don't have to do those
migrations anymore but this also speaks
to one question I had is about with a
company as big as Viacom CBS you're
dealing with a number of different
libraries or archives from different
entities and it seems that those can be
somewhat uniform within the company even
though the assets came from disparate
locations they probably came with all
manner of metadata or no metadata who
knows but are you seeing this as an
opportunity to create a uniform database
of all of this media that you now have
within Viacom CBS yeah that's definitely
the idea I mean it runs the gamut I mean
typically the amount of metadata that we
had and maintain it's really a function
of multiple things right but while I
think that there's definitely very much
aligned to is the value bath typically
the more valuable to ask the more effort
was put in to maintain the metadata and
catalog and you know in the in the the
we also have content that sort of you
know prefinished work as part of the
production process of what have you you
know especially you know 10 years ago 20
years ago again digital salade the level
catalog right so as we might way more
and more stuff to the plow and we're
leveraging things like AI and M now to
do things like automated video and audio
conformance on what a B there's also a
lot of opportunity to sort of Auto
metadata tagging and so again a lot of
our legacy contents that maybe doesn't
have the same amount of richness in
metadata right and and as we do more and
more this we will hopefully be able to
monetize
you know I didn't buy a new operator how
to music especially you know content
that we haven't touched in a long time
yeah and to that point a final question
is you mentioned the notion of the
different tiers of storage we have at
Google and how your retrieval times are
the same time to first byte on each tier
in my experience I'm noticing that a lot
of companies have their archive is not a
static thing it's an actually living
breathing thing and you're constantly
finding ways to monetize what's in there
is that part of the strategy at this
point with Viacom CBS is to start
leveraging some of the older content
that's been sitting in the archive that
may not have been as visible or as
searchable in the past yeah I mean it
really runs the gamut I mean you know
again we have you know things we had
things that are like the raw you know
and on the film saw in the television
size I say quite different on the film
side we have things that are for example
preservation masters which are the
original raw GPX files we probably won't
be necessarily working a lot against
those type of files per se right in that
space we will Bobby you know use sort of
like a mezzanine format you know so
there you know legacies or a magazine
mezzanine sort of content that we might
do the things that you're talking about
but you know who knows right in
five-year 10 years you know the thing
that seems to be relatively constant are
the quality of the content that people
want to seem to work again just you know
keeps going higher and higher right so
maybe somewhere down the road we might
be working directly against the original
preservation
that's great well Dan thank you again
for your time today thank you for
contributing to this and and thank you
for working with us so this has been
such a great project and we look forward
to many many more so and thank you all
for for listening and I hope you found
this useful and entertaining and expect
more to come from Viacom CBS at Google
cloth